foreign
out of Tacoma Washington hey Sarah
welcome to the show
hi
hello how can we help so
um I have two
um
things that I have going on in my
marriage
um oh you're lucky I've got like 15
things going on in my marriage I just
got two that's awesome
so one issue that I have is um
I'm sorry I'm trying to um
I I I noticed that my spouse has an
issue with uh drinking
and my second issue is
um our finances
um we have our finances separate and so
I not sure what he's doing with his
money and he's not sure what I'm doing
with my money
so I had a suggested marriage counseling
my spouse doesn't want to do it I had
suggest counseling for him he doesn't
want to do it so I'm like what do I do
next I'm like kind of are you safe
yes okay
um when you say he's got a problem with
alcohol what does that mean
um there's not a lot that can be done
with finances there's not a lot of work
that can be done on your marriage until
he's sober
um the person you left out of the
hey maybe we should go to marriage couns
and maybe you should go to marriage
counseling with me maybe you should go
to counseling the person you left out is
the only person you can actually do
something about and that's you
yeah I mean I'm going to counseling from
my own personal issues good for you but
it's kind of yeah it's kind of tough
when you have someone that's dealing
with their own demons and it's like
you know how am I supposed to
um get healthy how am I supposed to
um you know heal if I'm dealing with
someone I'm I don't want to say someone
when I'm dealing with a hurting spouse
when they have their own issues
absolutely I mean it's this is a
question millions of people ask are
forced to ask all the time how do I get
well in an unsafe environment and what I
would tell you is at some point you've
got to draw some boundary lines and say
whether that's I've got to take 30 days
and go stay with a friend I've got to
step right here for a minute and get my
head clear and get my relationships
clear and get my health clear
um or I'm gonna need to step away for 30
days uh on a very intentionally planned
uh separation here well you go get well
and if you're not interested in getting
well then I understand that you're not
interested in
um us working on this you see what I'm
saying like you're there's a point when
you have to draw some pretty firm
boundaries when you are married to
somebody who is struggling with
addiction because like you're noticing
it makes you financially insecure which
makes you at the end of the day very
unsafe
yeah right you don't know what he owes
what he's spending it on where it's
going if rent's going to get paid if
bills are going to get paid if you're
gonna have food in the fridge I mean
it's a very unstable way of being
yeah exactly and um and I tried to bring
it up and I'm like Hey listen listen you
can't
and I know that feels so powerless like
you can't fix him you know why you're
not the problem
you're not he's not doing this because
of you
and that's what makes this so hard is
that you love him and you want to just
snap your fingers and have it be okay
yeah how long have you guys been married
Sarah
um for four years four years how long
has you been drinking
um
two years
addiction and I don't think he's ever
got the proper help yeah yeah well I
don't think he is either yeah
um at the end of the day you can control
your thoughts and your actions and how
much you love him and then at some point
you've got to draw boundaries that make
sure you're safe and that you can have
peace
and those are very very complicated hard
conversations I'm glad you have a
relationship with a professional
counselor
and that's some
I'm sorry go ahead no no go go you're
good
yeah and that's something I'm talking
about in counseling where you know how
to draw
um boundaries and not be so like passive
how to say Hey you know if you continue
to do this like then I have to do this
that in the third that's right yeah so
that's something I'm learning in
counseling
and that's a new muscle to build Sarah
so give yourself some some Grace in that
you're right yeah if this is a new way
of looking at life in a new lens and
even a new way to communicate and say
out loud like that's scary right like if
there's even if there's like a level of
intimidation intimidation you don't want
to hurt him I mean there's so much and
if you've been a peacekeeper your whole
life when you're growing up if it was
your job to make sure not to say the
wrong thing because mom was going to fly
off the handle and dad would get mad
yeah
I don't like Conflict at all that's
right I really don't that's right
because it's like I don't like being in
situations like that because I know I
get super I'll get super super angry and
so that's something I'm learning
um also too is how to control my anger
and get my point across and if you've
been told your whole life
um how about you just shut up and you
make sure that everybody else is okay
first that what you need and what you
want and what you feel just gets
compressed like uh it just gets pushed
and pushed and eventually that stuff
comes out in Rage yeah right comes out
in race yeah and so here's the deal you
are like we tell people um who are on
baby step one when they're just trying
to get that thousand bucks and they've
been grinding at it for two months and
they're trying
you're on the right path it's just gonna
be hard because you're doing something
your body has never done before and it's
going to be tough
but you got this Sarah and you deserve
that right like there's to to have that
peace
um and not to go super tactical as we
end uh this segment but you mentioned
about the separate accounts and we come
on the show day in and day out telling
married couples join accounts join
accounts doing accounts except when
there's issues if there's a if there's a
divorce looming if there's a separation
if there's an addiction an addiction uh
we say that's a time to actually to keep
them separate so hear me say that loud
and clear that I would not combine
accounts with him uh with an addict
because it it it's not going to help the
situation you guys need to heal your
marriage first and then out of that
comes combining your accounts and
working together with your money but the
money is a totally side subject at this
point healing and getting boundaries for
you Sarah is the number one goal so
thank you so much for calling I hope
that helps